you guys let's hear from in your 20s
right it's amazing because I don't care
anymore it's perfect you think I'm
stupid I don't care you think I'm lazy I
don't care you don't think I'm pretty
why pretty I have a little sister she's
cute she's eight so when I take her up
people assume she's my kid
they're always like uh such a shame to
the baby so young who's the father I'm
like I don't know my dad
yeah they stop asking questions pretty
quickly after that I just moved here
from New York I live in a cool part of
town I live in like the part of town
where people go jogging with their dogs
but just stupid like me and my dog we've
an understanding we're never gonna go
jogging together like we have very
similar body types we're kind of short
stocky barrel-chested eight nipples
we're not going out but what I love is
in the cool neighborhoods you can find
these dudes that have this very specific
haircut it's like on the side and it's
shaved a little bit like to me it looks
like a Hitler Youth haircut which is
fine I feel like that's the mullet of
our time where it's like party on the
Left stick hi doctor guys
when I lived in New York I had a friend
with benefits right when you get one he
gets so excited you're just like I've
got a friend with benefits and
benefiting each other through friendship
hope he doesn't have any other friends
cuz I'm gonna find the men kill him and
like I tried to out and actually find
other friends to benefit with but this
is the problem you guys he was a hipster
Hasidic Jewish carpenter
I was Jesus you guys I used to dirty
talk to me in Yiddish I loved it I felt
like that girl who just found out she
likes to be choked but it's by 5000
years of Jewish culture
we used to roleplay uh that he was my
landlord which he was and that I was and
he would knock on my door and be like
missus agree no your rents due and I'd
be like Oh however shall I pay and then
we do it and then I'd pay him $800 but
I'm a plus-sized late it's here for
plus-sized [ __ ] for thousands of
years this was a desired body type it
said very specific things one I was
well-fed because I was rich - is that I
could carry a baby to full term and
three this body was resilient you want
to take this to pound town I'm the mayor
let's go
I want you guys to know that you're all
beautiful and wonderful all of you
except for one girl I met and I'll tell
you why I I did a show and afterwards
it's very little drunk thing came up to
me and she was like oh my god you're so
funny but like it is so hard to be
skinny and I was like okay why why is it
so hard and this is her reason because
sometimes your boyfriend wants to have
sex with your boobs and there's nothing
there that was it that was her whole
reason and at first I was mad I was like
screw that girl she's never gone into
store and not been able to get anything
she wants off the rack she has never
been thought of as being stupid or lazy
because what her body looks but you know
guys the entire time she was looking at
me and going oh my god that girl is so
lucky she has a spare vagina on her
chest
you know what guys if having two pieces
of flesh touch counts as a vagina I've
got a vagina here
[Applause]